bonjour je m'appelle justin de france et
je suis vulgarisatrice pan d'histoire
sur youtube si vous êtes ici vous êtes
abonné vous le savez probablement déjà
même si vous me connaissiez peut-être
uniquement sous le pseudo de la prof
si je fais cette vidéo aujourd'hui c'est
aussi pour une raison que vous
connaissez puisque vous avez
probablement lu le titre je sors à libre
on ça vient pas de nulle part
j'ai été contacté par les éditions
nouveau monde il ya deux ans et ça fait
environ un an et demi que je travaille
dessus
en plus de mme hachem et de mon métier
de ma vie s'est passé très vite mais
bref pourquoi ce livre qui est il qu'en
sortira-t-il et bien ce qui m'intéresse
dans la vulgarisation
c'est de traiter des thèmes qui peuvent
paraître large ou qu'ils subissent pas
mal d'idées reçues de nos jours et de
les aborder en profondeur par exemple
j'aime l'idée de ne pas rester à la
surface d'un thème comme les villes au
moyen-âge mais d'y apporter des détails
peu connu tout ça va de pair avec ma
démarche qui est d'écrire mes scripts à
partir de travaux distance je faisais
pas systématiquement au début de ma
chaîne mais ayant fait des recherches
d'histoire moi-même pendant mes études
ça me paraît important pour moi pour le
travail que j'apporte à mes vidéos et sa
part est aussi plus honnête pour les
gens qui la regarderont j'aime aussi
faire de l'histoire culturelle
l'histoire des mentalités parler du
quotidien des gens et non pas tes grands
personnages dans tout le monde a déjà
entendu pardon et donc mon livre découle
de cette envie de parler de la vie
quotidienne de traiter du moyen-âge
autrement que par ses rois et ses
guerres c'est pourquoi j'ai aborde en
dix chapitres des thèmes simples
l'alimentation les
justice la vie en ville en essayant d'y
traiter toutes les couches de la
population
bien sûr je ne peux pas tout est abordé
parce que le moyen-âge dur milan et
certains points restent méconnus faute
de sources
mais mon but est d'offrir un ouvrage
sérieux
du point de vue des recherches
effectuées pour l'écrire et accessible
au plus grand nombre
de par son style d'écriture et de par
des sujets qu'ils abordent du fait de
l'humour aussi les jolies images qui ont
été choisis par mes soins
bref j'espère que vous l'apprécierez
autant que j'ai aimé l'écrire il
s'appelle donc la vie quotidienne au
moyen-âge il sortira le 2 septembre et
je serai présente au rendez vous de
l'histoire de blois
les 7 et 11 octobre pour vous en parler
bien sûr en attendant et suite à ça les
vidéos continue gr jean todt a bad as
déjà écrit alors que demande le peuple
merci de votre attention passer un bel
été et à bientôt
c'est bien on peut arrêter de tourner en
fait je vous présente et oui